i hate intros my hero academia season 4
episode 1. we kick things off with the
introduction of taneo tokuda who is a
freelance journalist he speculates that
maybe all might's message after his last
fight was really directed at a successor
juco news gets him permission to visit
class 1a since all might has been
spending a lot of time with them he
suspects that the successor is in that
class
and goes to find out who it is shortly
after observing the class for a bit he
decides that the most likely candidate
is midoriya don't get to talks with
midoriya about a bombing at an
industrial complex that took place
18 years ago all 24 victims that were
caught up in the incident were saved by
all might and his dad was one of them so
he's a fan of all my also
we learned that his quirk is whole body
lens which allows him to spawn a camera
anywhere on his body including his dick
he confesses to midoriya that he wasn't
actually there to observe the life of
the students
really he was just curious if there was
a successor to all might for his own
peace of mind
after returning back to work he lies
saying that he jumped to the wrong
conclusions and didn't find anything
episode 2 we hop on over to the villain
side of things where the new villain
overhaul is brought to the league of
villains so that they can convince him
to join them
he has some different ideas though and
says that he wants them to work for him
this proposition escalates things to the
point that magnate attacks him only to
be killed by overhaul's quirk
when others go to subdue him mr compress
also loses an
arm before there's any more casualties
members of the shiehasikai yakuza come
to overhaul's aid deterring any more
bloodshed
back on over to midoriya who requests
that all might introduce him to his old
sidekick sir
night i for the work study program the
students have to take part in oh my
doesn't really want to talk to him
because of some incident that happened
in the past so he has together to take
midoriya to meet him instead
before the meeting together suggests
that if he wants to get on certain night
eyes good side he has to make him laugh
we then meet a new face in bubble girl
who is the only other person besides
together that works with sir nidai
but anyways with this in mind midoriya
opens with an all my impression that
actually just kind of pisses him off
episode three even though the opening
was kind of stale they're both all might
fanatic so they kind of hit it off
anyways
midoriya is then asked to prove that he
can be a part of the team by taking
knight i
stamp away from him so her night eyes
quirk allows him to see a person's
future
after touching them and making eye
contact with them midoriya tries his
best but can't get the stamp away from
him
even though he failed the test certain
night i was going to take him on
regardless if he passed or not so he
officially joins the agency this isn't
for the reasons you'd expect though as
his plan is to make midoriya realize
that he isn't the most suitable
successor to all might
he believes that together is the ideal
candidate and that he was the one that
should have inherited all might's powers
instead of midoriya
the other students are struggling to
find agencies that will take them on but
tokoyami ochaku asui and kiroshima
all managed to find openings over to
midori's first assignment where we
learned that they are already
investigating overhaul and the
shiehasakai episode 4.
not i am bubble check are watching over
halsumi doria and together go on patrol
while out they end up coming across a
little girl named arie who frantically
runs into the two of them
overhaul then comes out to retrieve the
girl acting like her father
the girl seems terrified but they don't
want to give away that they are
suspicious of overhaul
after midoriya suggests that he might
have done something to her overhaul says
that he can explain so they follow him
when he seems like he's about to get
violent aerys suddenly runs back to his
side to deter his attack
since they can't really do anything
midori and together decide to let them
go and report back to nidai they report
back what happened ending their first
day of the work study on a rather
ominous tone midori is kind of
conflicted about having to let the
little girl go so he goes to talk with
all might he confronts him about not
telling him that knight
i knew how his power worked and was
wanting all might to pass it on to
together
in response he tells me dory the story
of everything that had happened between
him and nidai
even though typically all might didn't
take on sidekicks knight i was such a
huge fanboy that they ended up working
together the partnership was dissolved
six years ago
after all might's injury all might was
in rough condition after his injury so
night i refuses to work with him anymore
and wants him to retire for his health
nigh i looked into all might's future
against his will and said that if he
continued like this he was going to die
a gruesome death at the hands of a
villain
that interaction didn't really go over
so well so the two haven't really talked
since then
shortly after the principal recommends
together to all might because he knew he
was looking for a successor however this
is right around the time that he meets
midoriya and gives his power to him
instead
after hearing that all might had passed
his power to a quirkless middle schooler
night i was opposed to this
in response to this he starts training
together in hopes of proving to all
might that he's a better successor than
midoriya now
i had seen six or seven years into all
might's future but the further into the
future he looks the harder it is to see
exactly when something will happen his
foresight has never been wrong though
and this means that all might will die
within this year or the next year in the
last scene all my amidoria agreed to
fight against fate and try to keep him
from dying
episode 5. we come in on a fight where
nigeria works with ochako and a suite to
take down some villains
they're all working for the dragoon hero
named ryuku who is the number nine hero
in the rankings
jay is the one that took on ochako and
esue for the work study program
turns out nai had made a request for
their two agencies to team up against
overhaul
over to tomara who meets with overhaul
to discuss a possible partnership under
the condition that they are
equals we don't really see what happens
with that though and then we hop on over
to tamaki who agreed to help kiroshima
get work under the hero that he works
with named
fat gum during a fight we see that
tamaki's quirk allows him to manifest
characteristics of things he
eats this makes him a rather formidable
hero but the only problem is that he has
cripplingly low self-esteem a man with a
gun suddenly appears and shoots a
thumbtack-looking bullet at the heroes
this bullet was made by overhaul and has
the ability to strip victims hit
of their quirk tamaki gets hit and can't
use his powers so kiroshima chases after
one of the culprits
once the guy gets coorded he shoots up a
drug that is designed to boost his
quirk's power
hiroshima is forced to use his new move
unbreakable
in order to prevent the new sharpened
blades from cutting him
he can only maintain this form for 30 to
40 seconds but in that time he takes
down the villain knowing that he's
inevitably gonna lose he tries to flee
but fat gum cuts him off and he is
finally apprehended
we learned that power booster drugs that
the man used are banned in japan and the
most potent ones can last an hour
episode 6 midoriya ochako asui and
kiroshima are all heading to the same
meeting when they arrive the big three
are also there
along with numerous pro heroes the
heroes discuss the shiiha sakai and how
they plan on
handling them they also pass along the
information of the drug that was
designed to temporarily strip a person
of their quirk
a racer head is able to nullify a
person's quirk but the drug seems to
damage the quirk instead hiroshima had
managed to block his second shot during
the commotion so they found and studied
that bullet
when studied they found that the bullet
contained human blood and
cells meaning that it came from
someone's power aka
a quirk that can destroy quirks we
learned that overhauls quirk allows him
to disassemble
and restore things being able to
completely break down matter
they speculate that overhaul is breaking
down aries body
into bullets and is planning to sell
them into the black market
not knowing where areas being kept now
they make a list of locations for the
heroes to investigate we also get the
fun fact that one of the restrictions to
naidi's power is that he can only look
into one person's future
every 24 hours he also doesn't seem
comfortable using it on any of the pro
heroes after the incident that happened
with all might
after the credits we see that arrow was
assigned a new caretaker but we don't
really know too much about him
episode 7 all of the heroes start their
investigation on the locations mentioned
at the meeting
after a couple of days everybody gets a
message that they've located arie
apparently she's being held in a
stronghold which is also the residence
of the head of the hossikai
now i managed to find the caretaker
looking after airy and uses his
foresight to guarantee he is the one
they're looking for everybody gets ready
to launch the operation to retrieve arie
from the haasekai
when they arrive they encounter
resistance from some of the henchmen
splitting up the heroes
midoriya and together are part of the
team that rush inside the residence to
find the girl
episode 8 we get a flashback of tamaki
being an awkward kid that nobody really
wanted to talk to together was the first
one to approach him which is how the two
met and he's looked up to together ever
since
back to the present where the heroes
continue storming the residence and
fighting off the henchmen attacking them
there's a villain
inside named irinaka whose quirk allows
him to go into objects and control them
as if they were his own body
as they make their way into the secret
tunnels irinaka uses a drug to boost his
power
he enters the walls and turns the
tunnels into a living maze
together doesn't give a [ __ ] about this
so he uses his powers to go ahead of the
others while phasing through the walls
meanwhile the others are forced into a
room where three villains toyah you
and sora mitsu are waiting to stall them
as long as possible
knowing that's their goal tamaki
volunteers himself to stay behind and
fight them so the others can go ahead
the three villains quickly break free
and start fighting back against him now
that a razor head wasn't around to
nullify their quirks but sequence ensues
and there are some back and forth before
the three of them are defeated by tamaki
episode 9. he used neurotoxins on the
villains which are now circulating
through their systems and will keep them
out of the fight although he's not doing
so high either so he falls unconscious
over to the elders where irinaka
separates fatcom and kiroshima from
their group
and they encounter two more villains
named kendo rappa and hikiji tengai
rapa's punches are messing them both up
which prompts a flashback
into kiroshima's past mino is actually
the one who inspired him to join ua
after she was brave on a couple of
different occasions
but anyways the flashback reinvigorates
kiroshima and he gets back into the
fight we learn that while fat gum is
absorbing
all of these shots he's actually storing
the power in order to turn it back on
the assailants kirishima jumps in to
block some of the punches and gives fat
gum an opening to unleash all of the
power that he had stored up defeating
both of the villains with one shot in
the last scene
[Music]
episode we see one of the new villains
named chronostasis who is escorting arie
ant overhaul to make their escape rapa
is too messed up to fight but he
acknowledges kiroshima's strength and
wants to fight him again sometime
we get our first official look at the
villain in the walls joy iranaka who
decides it's time to use his trump card
the walls start warping again and begin
to close in to crush the heroes
and while that's going on rapa explains
that the only reason he's working for
the hasakai is because overhaul was the
only person
ever to beat him overhaul had killed him
with his quirk and then brought him back
to life five times
after that he realized he's probably not
gonna win so he agrees to join him in
hopes of one day beating him in a fight
back on over to the others where the
hero rock lock has the ability to freeze
things in place
so he uses this to counteract the walls
closing in on them
midoriya kicks through the other walls
that he can't get to completely negating
ironaka's strategy
once that had failed he falls back to
his next plan which is to create walls
to separate all of them
rock lock is then ambushed by himiko and
twice who use their quirks to stab
him midoriya can hear the commotion
through the walls so he breaks it down
and finds rock lock incapacitated
eraserhead then breaks himiko's disguise
revealing her as she attacks midoriya he
manages to avoid the attack but she did
succeed in stabbing erase her head
before making her escape
after that she rendezvouses with twice
and it's revealed that they're only
pretending to work together with the
yakuza but are
actually planning to make them pay for
killing magnay they then antagonize
iranaka who goes into a rage in the last
scene
episode 11. we learned that overhaul had
perfected the drugs so now it can
permanently destroy a perk instead of
having it wear off
but back to the league of villains plan
which entails using the heroes to get
back at the haasek high
this plan seems to work out pretty well
because in irrinaka's rage he
accidentally reveals his position and
eraserhead nullifies his quirk
and while that's going on together had
finally managed to catch up to overhaul
overhaul leaves behind two villains in
nematode and sakaki to deal with them
together uses his ability to fight
through them and get to arie
overhaul uses his perk to cut off his
escape forcing together to fight back
against him and chronostasis
during the fight nematode gets one of
the perk destroying bullets to shoot
together he knows it's likely that he's
going to be able to dodge the bullet
using his quirks so he instead
aims at airy together jumps in front of
the bullet to protect her and his quirk
is destroyed but despite that he still
immediately continues fighting back in
the last inn he is stabbed by one of
overhaul spikes
but before he has killed midoriya breaks
through one of the walls
episode 12. me dorya a racer head and
night i bust into the room and
immediately land a shot on overhaul
eraserhead is nullifying his power but
chronostasis wakes up to attack
eraserhead creating an
opportunity for overhaul to attack the
others
in the chaos overhaul finds a moment to
destroy himself
and the moto and then fuses together
with him which kills nimoto in the
process
chronostasis had wound up with a racer
head where we learned that anybody
struck by his attacks will have their
movements slow to a crawl
he also wants to take a racer head
captive since overhaul has an interest
in him because he can erase quirks
nadai orders midoriya to look after
together and airy while he fights
overhaul
during the fight we learn that nidai is
scared that if he looks into somebody's
future
then he is dictating the course that
their life will take he fears that by
using his sight to look into all might's
future he may have inadvertently
caused almight's imminent death this is
why he feels so strongly about not
looking into people's distant futures
but anyways back to the fight nige is
impaled and severely wounded so midoriya
has to jump in to save him midoriya also
gets impaled and this leaves an opening
for
overhaul to use nemato's quirk to speak
to arie
he convinces her to come back because if
she doesn't then he's gonna kill
everybody
she reluctantly comes back and agrees to
cooperate as long as he heals everybody
that he had hurt in the fighting not
willing to accept that midoriya pushes
himself to keep fighting we then learned
that nida had apparently looked into
overhaul's future and saw that he kills
midoriya and escapes with arie
this cues the entrance of ochaku asui
and ryuku
in the last scene i'm gonna be doing
part two and you can find that on the
left side whenever i'm finished with it
or you can check out all the my hero
academia recaps in the playlist on the
right side you can also find the links
in the description below and the only
thing i hate more than intros is
outros